[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: You're working hard
to provide your customers
with the best customer
experience possible,
whether that's through
machine learning applications,
chat bots, or mobile messaging.
At Google Cloud, we want to
make it as easy as possible
for you to adopt virtual
agents and bots, which
need to be integrated
with Enterprise system
and processes.
That's why Apigee, which is
Google Cloud's API management
platform, has
native capabilities
to make it easier
and faster to get
started with conversational AI.
The specific challenge
we're tackling
is connecting conversational AI
products, such as DialogFlow,
with your backend systems,
especially legacy systems.
Our goal is to make
the deployment of bots
and virtual agents faster,
giving your team's time
back to focus on innovation.
And give your customers a
stellar customer experience
with speedy replies and
orchestrated responses.
Let's talk about how
Apigee can do this.
Apigee is an intuitive
platform for bot designers
and architects to incorporate
key business function
and insights into the workflow.
It acts as an API
fulfillment engine,
essentially enabling
DialogFlow to talk
to your backend systems.
It does this in three ways.
Your IT teams can get your
conversational AI deployment up
and running quickly, while still
focusing on other modernization
efforts.
Your conversation
architects don't need
to spend time integrating APIs.
They can focus on building
great voice experiences
for your customers.
And all your teams can
build APIs once, and reuse
across different use cases.
Apigee has native policies
available within the UI that
will make the API fulfillment
process even more turnkey.
These policies can pars
DialogFlow requests,
set DialogFlow responses,
and validate parameters
captured by DialogFlow.
I built a simple flow
in DialogFlow CX that
allows someone to rent a car.
The user is asked when and where
they want to pick up the car.
They pick a specific car,
confirm some details,
and the rental
reservation is booked.
Let's run in the simulator
and see how it works.
Hello.
I'd like to rent a car.
San Jose, California.
No.
June 13th, 3:00 PM.
June 15th, 9:00 AM.
Yes, that sounds good.
Let's go with the Charger.
Yes.
Visa.
412341234.
John Smith.
2930 Pearl Street,
Boulder, Colorado 80301.
80301.
It was easy for me to rent
a car with this agent.
The conversation was natural
and the agent was responsive.
You may have noticed the list
of parameters in the simulator.
DialogFlow allows
you to store pieces
of information and parameters.
Some of these come from
what the user says,
and others are retrieved
from backend services.
A big part of creating a good
conversational application
is integrating with
backend systems.
DialogFlow lets you
specify a webhook
to connect with backend systems.
For example, I used a
webhook in the list vehicle
step of my flow.
When the conversation
reaches this step,
DialogFlow will make a call
to the backend system that
has car inventory information.
In this demo, I used Apigee
to build a set of APIs
for my agent.
Apigee lets you quickly
build and manage APIs.
Apigee has two new policies just
for working with DialogFlow.
If we look at the step
where the agent lists
which cars are
available, we can see
that it uses the Get Vehicles
webhook in the Search Cars tag.
Let's look at the
definition for that webhook.
For the webhook URL, I
provided the URL for the API
on managing in Apigee.
I also supplied a
client key from Apigee
that will be passed
as an HTTP header.
This client key
identifies the application
and lets Apigee control
access to the APIs it manages.
Next, let's look at how
this API works in Apigee.
In Apigee, I
created an API proxy
to handle requests
from DialogFlow.
I've configured a set of
Apigee policies over here,
and I have a series of flows
that handle specific requests.
The proxy endpoint pre flow
is called for our request.
I also have four
conditional flows
that will be called
depending on which
tag is specified in the
webhook fulfillment setting.
In the pre flow, there
are three policies.
The first checks the API key
that is passed in the header.
If the key is
missing or invalid,
an unauthorized
response is sent.
Otherwise, the flow continues.
Next, I remove the
client key header,
since it's no longer needed.
The third policy is an instance
of parsed DialogFlow request,
one of the new
policies for working
with DialogFlow in Apigee.
Messages sent from DialogFlow
have a JSON payload
that contains the intent,
session ID parameters, and more
that are sent with
the webhook request.
Parsed DialogFlow request
takes his information
and turns it into
variables that can be
referenced in this Apigee flow.
Let's turn on the trace
and see how it works.
If we look at the trace,
we can see all the details
of what happened in Apigee
when the webhook was called.
The request enters here.
A number of policies are called.
We'll notice here in the
parse DialogFlow request
that a whole bunch of
variables got created.
And those were
based on parameters
that were present in our
session in DialogFlow.
All of these will be
available at the Apigee flow
and can be used in
different policies.
We set a condition to
follow a conditional flow
based on the value of
the fulfillment tag.
In this case, the fulfillment
tag was equal to Search Cars,
and this was a post request.
So that particular
flow was followed
and these steps were executed.
Let's look at the
flow that manages
the booking of a reservation.
This flow calls out
to a Cloud function.
The Cloud function
requires authentication.
The first two policies
in here make a call
to the Google Cloud
Identity Management system.
They send some credentials that
I stored in Apigee's key value
map.
Those credentials are
exchanged for a token
that I can pass in a header to
the call to my Cloud function.
The next policy is the
call to the Cloud function
that will make a reservation.
I send the token in
several parameters
that were sent from DialogFlow.
The car description, the
start date, the end date,
and the location.
Apigee then makes a call
to the reservation service
and reserves a car.
The response is
stored in a variable
called Reserve Results.
The next policy is an
extract variable policy.
And it's used to
retrieve the reservation
ID and the reservation total
from the response from the call
to the reservation system.
Next I use a set
DialogFlow response policy
to send the reservation
ID and total back
to DialogFlow's parameters.
DialogFlow uses that information
to confirm the reservation
with the customer.
Using Apigee to manage the
APIs needed by DialogFlow
allows a conversation
designer who's
building things in
DialogFlow to focus
on providing an excellent
user experience,
rather than worrying about how
to integrate with Enterprise
systems.
It allows an API
developer to quickly build
a set of experienced APIs
to support this application.
They can hide away
the complexities
in the backend services.
This won't be the
last API we need
to build for this project or
something else that requires
access to backend services.
But establishing a
standard pattern for this
will save us a lot of
time in the long run.
Apigee, and the two new policies
specifically for DialogFlow
make this easy to do.
Now it's your turn
to try it out and get
started by following the links
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]